So let's apply what we just learned to help complete our interpreter to fill out what it means
to evaluate statements.
Previously, we had an evaluate function expression.
Now I'm going to make a new function for evaluating statements.
It's going to take the abstract syntax tree and also the environment.
We need to know the values of variables.
As always by convention, we can get the type of the thing we're looking for
from the 0th part of the tuple.
We did all this work in the parser to record it. Let's totally take advantage of that.
Well, 1 possibility is that it's an assignment statement.
Those look something like this.
Here's our statement type, assignment,
and its first argument or the first part of its tuple is going to be some variable name
that we're assigning to, and then the second part is going to be
an arbitrary expression abstract syntax tree,
so that corresponds to x becomes 3.
So I'll just get out the variable name and get out the right_child abstract syntax tree.
I'll figure out what the new value is by calling evaluate expression
because this right-hand side part could be more complicated.
For example, it could be a binop of a bunch of things,
so we're going to need to walk down that tree and interpret it--translate it
to figure out what it means.
Now we've got the new value,
and we'll just promise ourselves later on we're going to write some new function
called environment update that changes the environment so that variable_name
now points to new_value.
This should remind you a lot of the chart update procedure that we wrote before.
However, there are other types of statements.
In addition to assignments, there are if-then-else.
There are typically 3 parts of if-then-else.
The conditional expression--suppose our if-then-else is if x 00:01:48,000
I haven't drawn in the curly braces to save space, but this is the general idea--
then our conditional expression is x 00:01:56,000
The then statements are A. The else statements are B.
But before we go farther, there is 1 complicating factor.
Remember that in JavaScript, you can have multiple statements inside this
compound statement block.
So really, we have then statement s and else statement s.
Your mission is to complete this code, and you can assume that there's a procedure
called eval_stmts that takes statements as an argument and an environment.